hey guys and welcome to another wait a
minute is this one the one before
christmas
is this the christmas episode
yeah dude hello
ho ho ho welcome to a very christmas
episode of congratulations
[Music]
all good dude it is a christmas franken
miracle that we are still
absolutely farting in all syllables and
but unless we are unless we are
it is december 22nd and you have three
days until christmas which means i have
four days until i start my christmas
shopping because i do it afterwards
because when i do it before it's too
hard things get lost in the mail uh the
malls are too crowded and everyone's
like hey chrisley can have a picture and
i gotta chill baby i gotta chill
um
but yeah dude it is almost christmas so
if you need that last minute gift idea
go to crystalia.com pick up some merch
and then you can just print out the
picture and be like i got you this if it
doesn't come in time and who knows it
might because i use ship station and
that [ __ ] goes immediately and then also
uh you can do even a gift certificate
there and then also you can hit me up on
cameo because you boys collecting racks
[Music]
we love racks here at congratulations so
ho-ho-ho or my my son would say
oh it's very cute um what does i say he
just started saying santa he was saying
sassa and now he's saying santa and then
he said what does santa say and he says
ho ho ho and it's very cute and that's
it
um
but yeah love makes the world go round
um man i love him and
you know it's been a pretty cool uh
week uh at cr at uh to crystalia at the
dalia household uh
self-centered calling it the crystallia
household and um but it's great my
my uh my jaw hurts got it feel it all up
in my [ __ ] ear so that's great dude
that is so [ __ ] great i feel my jaw
in my ear and it hurts my ear and me
having tmj just sort of hurts my ear
that's so [ __ ] great dude people say
[ __ ] to me and i don't hear them not
even because i can't hear them but
because of the pain yes dude love having
pain on one side and then it eeks out
over on the other side because it's
sympathetic hey yes man i love that [ __ ]
dude i freaking love it man
so that's cool man pain all good
right um
and then kristen went to go get her ear
wax removed and um and that's cool then
we started talking about it and and then
uh one fire was like i want to get my
ear ears cleaned
and then uh he was like i think i want
to go to the ear doctor and get my ears
cleaned and then i just said daily
beloved like it was six months from now
and he died and then we all laughed we
had a good time but that's the kind of
[ __ ] humor we do here at
congratulations studios and uh and it
was great do it and you guys weren't
here and i really told it and this is
one of these stories where i guess he
had to be there and it's true and that's
why i'm telling it
i don't like to guess you had to be
their thing you understand because of
course you had to be there that's why
i'm telling you the goddamn story why
would you why would i tell you a story
about something that happened that i
don't think you should be there
that's a bad story
so saying i guess he had to be there
it's mood
oh oh you're you know what you are
you're a slow breeze you don't matter
you don't push [ __ ] around you're a slow
breeze
and it's already 72 degrees
be more memorable baby right that's why
i say this [ __ ] don't be some guy that
just comes out and says these terms that
are around make up your own [ __ ]
like yolo
right i don't you know yolo is old but
and you know
if you say yolo now honestly it's
probably cool you're probably [ __ ]
cool if you say yellow now because that
was what 2014
i don't know what it was but yolo dude i
say yolo now and that's [ __ ] awesome
i gotta wear sunglasses more man it's
just [ __ ] my [ __ ] is so bright
um but yeah yolo dude and and who knows
even if yolo you might live more than
once
you you only live once you know
em
maybe you live m-y-l-m-t-o
l-i-m
i can't do it i gotta [ __ ] type it
out goddammit maybe you live more than
maybe you live maybe maybe you live more
than
once
milom toe dude that's my new [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] yeah dude milam doe
twice because maybe you live more than
once dude milam toe anyway um that's not
funny at all but i did it and uh so yeah
dude yeah dogs are barking dude there's
too many dogs in my house man not only
do i have my dogs but i got [ __ ]
friends over and they got their dogs and
[ __ ] and uh anyway dude uh what was i
saying we got their ears done dude have
you ever gotten your ears unclogged you
go to the doctor and they just put
saline in your ears and you keep your
ear to the side for a little bit and
then you just dump it out it seems
pretty archaic but when you dump it out
dude it's like you blew your nose
it's gross
and it's terrible but it feels so good
and i don't know if it actually feels
good or if one of those things that
feels good or if it's one of those
things that you think feels good because
you could just hear better i don't know
if it actually is a feeling i suppose if
you have a lot of real real hardcore
pressure on uh your ear maybe it does
make it feel good but uh when you get it
out but i don't know i don't know and it
doesn't matter either way but you should
get your but i i did that and i could
hear way better once
and uh and so i got to do it again and i
think that uh and kristen just did it
and then also one fire is going to do it
so if you can't hear go get your [ __ ]
ears unclogged but uh who cares anyway
i'm gonna be at the [ __ ] oxnard
oxnard improv january 14th to 16th i'm
gonna do crystalia and friends that's
what i'm gonna do you know your boy's
building his material you know your
boy's building his material and he
doesn't have an hour yet so it's going
to be crystallia and friends so come on
down to oxnard uh and uh
california and come check your boy out
uh january 14th to 16th and uh
that's it
i did fight companion the other day and
we watched pourier uh
dustin poirier lose i love that guy that
guy is a class act that guy [ __ ] wins
and he's nice unless you talk [ __ ] and
he loses and he's nice dude if you talk
[ __ ] he's basically not nice don't talk
too much [ __ ] don't cross the line
but also
such a class act dude the guy lost and
then [ __ ] hug the dude and told the
dude that he's gonna [ __ ] donate to
the dude's charity
a class [ __ ] act dude i like that
kind of guy how crazy is it dude you see
these fighters come and go you see these
flashes in the pan and then you see the
dudes that are just the jeff bridges of
the ufc you know what i mean they start
okay okay good yeah we respect them
great cool cool and then all of a sudden
he's doing that [ __ ] movie where
you're like whoa okay and he's [ __ ]
at the end of his career now i'm not
saying justin poury is the end of his
career he's a young dude but you know
the end of a ufc fighter's career is
like 32 years old and i think he's 32
years old
but the guy just stepped up into the hot
sauce game dude and that is where see
that's the thing dude you got to get
that extra thing to make you outlive
a young man's game and dustin poirier
took [ __ ] hot sauce and elevated this
[ __ ] and he sent me some and it's good
as [ __ ] dude he sent me the hot hot [ __ ]
which i use it's very hot and also the
nice mild [ __ ] and i use nice mild chip
when i kind of want to take it when all
my taste buds say kind of take the day
off because you know you know you know
your boy goes nuts with the hot sauce i
do i just [ __ ] throw tabasco on it
people are like cholula and i'm like no
i keep it old school with the tabasco
and i'll sprinkle it on right
but i'll sprinkle it but it's not so
much of a sprinkle as it's more it's a
bunch of sprinkles right because i like
when tabasco come out it looks like a
penis [ __ ] it does now i didn't i
didn't make that happen i you know what
i mean like i'm not jesus christ so
don't be all like ill
you you know what i mean when i say when
tabasco comes out it looks like a penis
[ __ ] you know what i mean right
because it does okay because it likes
kind of squirts out a little bit and
then fast and then a little
a little less and then fast and then
fast and you're like whoa is this you
know what i mean
come on you had never went there well
mine did and now yours has to every
single time you use goddamn tabasco
sauce
um so yeah but justin poirier has got
he's got that [ __ ] has got real good
hot sauce he really does and um
and i'm upset that he lost honestly i'm
a big fan of his and uh but but it's
okay dude you just keep moving man
right losing is only as bad as you as it
is in your head
i get those competitive [ __ ]
out there like some comics are
competitive they're like i gotta be the
best guy on the show if you just drop
that if you drop that competitive nature
like dude people act like they're
[ __ ] six oh i gotta win what do you
have to win what for what for your ego
what are you [ __ ] six dude i'm 41. if
i'm not a better comedian than another
person i'm on the show with and the
crowd is more vibing with that dude
all good man
all good
some people need to put the [ __ ]
furniture together and that can be me
maybe that's my hot sauce
maybe that's my next career
right maybe i go out on the road now i
start doing dates and you know i i'm not
feeling it
maybe i'll become a carpenter
maybe the crowd's not feeling it maybe i
become a [ __ ]
maybe i'm the best valet around
and that's okay dude
um
but conor mcgregor is [ __ ]
hey dude this is the thing i love man
this is the thing i love about this is
the thing i love
about
what how do i even say this uh
getting yoked okay
hey and i've said this before in this
podcast but hey
it's if you think a guy's on steroids
he's on steroids
okay it's like when you think someone's
gay and then you realize it and you're
like oh yeah
just come on over to the side
come on over the side of belief you look
at hugh jackman and one of the [ __ ]
wolverine movies especially like the
fourth one the bad one whatever the bad
one was dude you're like oh is he on
roids no you're like oh i love how they
they ask him hey what was your favorite
[ __ ] what was what was your workout
how did you do it how did you what did
you eat oh what did i eat
i ate chicken but the main thing was i
injected steroids in my ass
you don't get that [ __ ] popping out
unless you do the juice
and conor mcgregor gained 36 pounds in
six months partially yeah i get it okay
his ankle's bad so he's not able to do
cardio okay but it's 36 pounds of a
muscle
not fat the guy looks stacked i mean he
looks so [ __ ]
i mean this dude looks so beefed up he
went from irish to russian look at his
face
he just you know who he looks like the
[ __ ] uh the the the you know who he
looks like the [ __ ] uh a guy that
would be like hey go [ __ ] yourself boy
he looks like a straight up yolked
southern american
hey boy you know where the [ __ ] uh
i does that he looks like he'd pull up
on you conor garter looks right now like
he'd pull up on you in a [ __ ] ford
truck an old ford truck and be like hey
do you know if that gas station is
letting you [ __ ] [ __ ] in it if you
don't have to buy if you don't buy
something or do i have to [ __ ] buy
some [ __ ]
that's what conor mcgregor looks like
that guy now
with a beard that's just [ __ ] it's
like a cartoon the dude uses hey guys
guys who aren't sure let me clear this
up dude he's juicing
the guy's back looks like a goddamn
pterodactyl
he's
juicing
he could he's got one of those [ __ ]
uh he look those
his lats look like one of those [ __ ]
red bull outfits that guys do when they
jump off the mountain and just glide
through a [ __ ]
like a a a hole in the mountain
connor you're juicing it's all good but
let's stop with the what's your workout
plan i do a few chin-ups eat some
chicken and then i shoot up in my in my
[ __ ] ass
i inject
i inject drugs in my ass and that's why
i look like [ __ ] uh what's that guy's
goddamn
name
god damn it [ __ ] [ __ ] the geba
penton's working overtime dude i took
one last night god damn it sucks dude
no not the rock one fire
it dude
firing on one syllable i'm pissed off
dude this is unbelievable dude i miss
one goddamn thing and then one fire is
all chiming in with the rock n i'm not a
[ __ ] hack i was trying to think of
the rocksteady and b block from teenage
mutant ninja turtles
rocksteady
bebop
[ __ ] yeah dude finally
god dude the gabapentins
anyway
you didn't help you helped with the
whole [ __ ] disaster and then your boy
cleaned it up it's all good but [ __ ]
milemato
maybe you live more than
once
wow
so petered out
when i said maybe you live only more
than once uh maybe live more than once i
don't know dude whatever
anyway conor mcgregor is now a southern
american guy that asks you if you can
[ __ ] if you can use the [ __ ] in
the gas station without buying something
so that's who conor mcgregor is and it's
all good and you can't [ __ ]
la
can't tell me what's that [ __ ]
you can't tell me nothing la wait till i
get my am i mixing up two songs who
knows gabapentin i have received the
trouble thank you
it's all good hey gabapentin thank you
for delivering the trouble in my life
all good i'm less good of a podcaster
because of the gabapentin that subsides
my anxiety
gabapentin i hear you loud and clear
thank you for the trouble delivery i've
received it i don't want it but i'm
using it um so yeah man that's what's up
oh also there's new go medium and
speaking of [ __ ] using the juice dude
relax on the juice man it's not a good
idea to use the juice
especially if you're not some guys use
steroids just to use steroids
like you're just guy hanging out you're
just some dude that sometimes goes to
the park with your family and has like a
steak night with fellas
and you're just doing juice dude
you're cycling you're in the cycle
guy who went to a guy who went to a
[ __ ]
uh pta meeting once because his wife
couldn't make it and you went instead oh
you're cycling
you're doing a cycle
[ __ ] that man
i'm doing i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do
trt and i'm gonna be so bulked up i
swear to god and i'm not even lying and
i'm telling you that right now that i've
not ever done steroids you know me i
don't do any drugs i take a small dose
of xanax sometimes when i want to go to
zany island because your anxiety is
knocking on my chest right
and the doctor prescribed it but i've
done none of that steroids trt [ __ ] one
day i'm gonna do that [ __ ] and you're
gonna see your boy so bulked up in six
months thought i'm gonna talk cause my
muscles are in the way of my neck
people are gonna be like why is dalia
keep passing out oh dude i honestly he
does he did so much trt that his [ __ ]
throat muscles are closing up does he
work out his throat no he just eats a
lot of chicken and he works out does a
lot of chin-ups and push-ups but dude
the boy does so much trt that his throat
closed up because of the muscles in his
neck jesus christ
that's how the conversation's gonna go
anyway dude conor mcgregor is on the
juice and i don't like the juice but i
[ __ ] up and i said it he's on juice
so yeah we got to go new go medium and
sometimes stay out color ways
and they're so [ __ ] sick with it dude
i'm sorry man
it's like what am i doing oh they're so
sick i'm so they're so sick with it they
are so [ __ ] sick with it you might as
well rub [ __ ] robitussin on them for
real i hope they get better
i hope these [ __ ] designs get better
and i don't mean that they're not
visually and aesthetically pleasing i
mean they're so sick with it
oh [ __ ] dude i gotta take my hoodies to
the doctor oh [ __ ]
this sucks i hope i don't catch it
so go to crystallia.com and go meet him
and sometimes stay out
don't even have to say the colors you
trust me
i saw the drake and kanye concert and it
was just like okay
okay
we're done i'm done with concerts for
real and i've been done with concerts
i've been done with concerts
i'm friends with musicians i'm friends
with people who do concerts i'm done i
just give me your cd i'm good and i
don't even like give me the itunes link
or whatever the [ __ ] apple music
whatever it is spotify if you're a
highfalutin i [ __ ] with apple music you
know
but yeah dude i mean like
the the concerts just these concerts
these these musicians or whatever you
want to call them rappers or musicians
or guitarists or even if you're a guy
with like a [ __ ] who is that jack
johnson with his bare feet that [ __ ]
the guy
cuck singing with no shoes on
like dude where where are all the
clothes bro
when you got a guitar
so um
anyway guys probably worth like 50
million dollars but um kanye and um
drake had the concert the free larry
hoover concert right now one thing about
me is
i don't know who
and we'll never know who larry hoover is
okay
i just can't be bothered to google call
me ignorant don't care
do you know what i don't like though
causes
all good now i'm growing and i'm [ __ ]
trying to be not so narrow-minded i'm
trying to open up my doors but one thing
at a time dude i started doing therapy
about a year and a half ago and i've
been doing so much therapy to choke a
horse just let me have my [ __ ]
[ __ ] causes
just let me [ __ ] take slow steps
right you gotta walk before you can run
and i'm telling you right now me getting
behind the cause
it's running
there's too many causes out there and i
don't trust [ __ ] nobody
free hillary who is he some [ __ ]
crime guy that ran drugs or some [ __ ] i
think probably i think that's who he is
and he [ __ ] orchestrated some
killings okay oh why he's in jail
unjustly is he i don't know i'll let
everybody else figure out dude the
second somebody is fighting so hard on a
cause
especially if they're famous you gotta
watch out for that [ __ ] person
because you can't trust them because you
don't why are they so hard of the cause
they don't know much they don't know the
actual [ __ ] and i get it do your own
research you think kanye west and drake
are doing their own research those are
from [ __ ] who have no lives
doing your own research
isn't for a guy on a jet that he owns
you think they're on the planes on
[ __ ] reddit well hold on let me check
this subreddit dude he's in his billion
dollar yacht getting sucked off
you think a guy who wears only versace
and
uh [ __ ] what do you call those
goddamn slippers the house slippers that
he makes and sells
worth a company with worth six billion
dollars you think a guy like that is on
his yacht
[ __ ] round with subreddits
dude
these causes that these people get
behind because all of a sudden they're
the bass player of you two
these causes that people get behind
because all of a sudden dude
you're somebody in the limelight you got
to be wary of these [ __ ]
you got to be wary why because why
yeah you could be doing it for the
[ __ ] real reason look i really want
to be a a
an outspoken person
but i'm gonna trust a [ __ ] mentally
unwell dude
that sings scoop diddy whoop doop doop
because he wants to let somebody got a
prison
i'm gonna trust a guy
i'm gonna trust a guy who sells [ __ ]
slot
bright orange slides and crocs that are
bright red with holes in them that make
six billion dollar years off of the
brand that sings
i'm such a [ __ ] hoe i love it sad
runner just because he says free a guy
out of prison i don't know so you know
what i stay out of it
because i can't
i can't act like these guys are doing
their own research and actually figuring
it out when there are actually people
who are doing their own research and
actually figuring it out that are not on
billion dollar yachts getting sucked off
eating those orange eggs that [ __ ]
every sushi place has while they're
getting sucked off eating those [ __ ]
orange eggs at the sushi place
[Laughter]
saying [ __ ] scoop diddy whoop doop
doop getting sucked off busting in her
mouth while eating all those [ __ ]
hundreds of orange of eggs that the
sushi place gives you for some reason
that i've never eaten who orders that
[ __ ] the [ __ ] guy getting sucked off
in the billion dollar yard
dude if you had a [ __ ] reality show
on goddamn what's it what's the [ __ ]
home garden network or what the hell the
learning channel and it was just called
uh billion dollar yachts and the guys
who get sucked off on them the bill for
that [ __ ] for those orange eggs that
the sushi places would have would be so
astronomical dude
i swear to god
i'm i mean you know yeah i get it i get
why people don't listen to this podcast
but for those of you that do
oh [ __ ] i can't wait to get that goddamn
log cabin and sit in the tall grass and
share ideas
oh man
because your boys makes their boy makes
so much [ __ ] sense it's unbelievable
yeah sometimes kristen doesn't think so
and yeah sometimes she thinks i'm wrong
when i say things but come on dude it's
like
i want to be like you're not listening
though
i can't believe it's almost christmas
um
i don't know no you know what i can it
always happens at the same amount of
time i don't want to be one of those
guys that's like i can't believe that
this is happening already even though it
happens 365 to 365 days
um
but yeah are you ready i'm never ready
i'm never ready for christmas man
i'm never ready with the gifts i always
have to [ __ ] print one thing out on
on the printer and be like this is what
you're getting in [ __ ]
on the 28th
you know what i'm saying
this is what you're getting you know
you're that [ __ ] you're listening
right now you know you're that [ __ ]
to somebody right
this year
how much are you and you're [ __ ]
smiling right now right because i got
your number
you're just oh [ __ ] the toaster didn't
come in time i got a [ __ ] goddamn i
gotta find a good picture of it on the
internet and just print it out and give
it to him in an envelope it'll be nice
i'll put a bow on it like you're not an
[ __ ] because you put a bow on it
or you know what are you that [ __ ]
gift giver that does the [ __ ]
non-wrapping thing where you just put it
in a bag and some cellophane over it
like a piece of [ __ ]
dude just hand it to me as a matter of
fact throw it at me
don't give me a bag with some [ __ ]
with some uh
tissue paper just popping out of it like
you did something
these [ __ ] here you go and then
you got some beats by dre in a [ __ ]
bag in some glossy bag with santa on a
sleigh
and like some [ __ ] green uh tissue
paper coming out of it like you're not a
piece of [ __ ] like you saved someday
go [ __ ] yourself dude don't ever [ __ ]
hand me a present like this you hand me
a present like this i don't receive it
dude
with your [ __ ] pinching ass [ __ ] i
don't receive it dude hand it to me like
this like it's a goddamn cake you
rapped or i'm not involved dude i don't
receive it
or j i'd i'm telling you don't even wrap
it just give it to me i'm i'm 41 i don't
want to unwrap [ __ ] i get my knees all
close together so it doesn't fall off i
fall through my legs i don't want to do
that [ __ ] i ain't no [ __ ] hand me the
gift would you get me an iron hand it to
me and matter of fact take it out of the
box just
maybe i want i want to think you maybe
got it on craigslist
the less [ __ ] i got to do the better
take the earphones out i want to wake up
if you got me some beats by dre i want
to wake up with them on my head and have
you looming over me and being like merry
christmas
the less i got to do the better my baby
god the last right it's like
these people like uh kevin hart and the
rock and dude i met rob dierdrich the
other day i did them i did do this
[ __ ] i love this dude this guy
is you know what he is he's a
[ __ ] mint he is golden dude rob
dierdrich is the [ __ ] the guy's so nice
so good and you know what this guy has
that a lot of people don't have
something about him
you can't put your finger on he's like
this mysterious kind of guy that looks
like he chills on the beach a lot
skin is nice
laughs makes you feel like you're the
only guy in the room
when he talks to you
he's engaged
right the guy's super nice
makes a boatload of money
i don't know what from you know i know
ridiculousness he does it's like on
season [ __ ] 500 but he he creates
five four or five companies a year and
sells them that's what he's that's what
he told to me now a guy like me
doesn't know what that means
what do you mean
is there a product involved
or do you just what's going on is this a
crypto thing
hi dude is this nft based what do you
mean you start a company five times a
year and then sell it
i don't know what that means i will
never know what that means but that's
what he said to me
and he looked like a million dollars
when he said it all right
so guys like that i mean after the
[ __ ] fighter podcast fighter in the
companion podcast dude we did that [ __ ]
after we watched [ __ ] two guys duke
it out for way too long right
and we talked about everything but
fighting because i was on and i
commandeer because your boy provides a
bomb
right i had to commandeer the
conversation and it's okay when i do
that because your boy provides bombing
views
all right
so i did that and we were talking about
it and i was like god you do so much
[ __ ] and he's like i don't really eat
pizza that much i got what i eat i start
every day i write something lovely to my
wife and i'm just like whoa this guy's
got it all figured out
he really does rob dyrdek has it all
figured out in the best possible way
and when i meet a guy that's got it all
figured out like him kevin hart the rock
i go like this
oh
wow
i give up
i didn't realize no i don't give up i'm
realizing i gave up
because the second you know whenever you
meet a guy like that that's so good at
talking and being engaging and [ __ ]
has hundreds of million dollars or
whatever the [ __ ] it is and they're
always working what do you think you
always think immediately the first is
like huh i wonder what my version of
that is i bet i could do that somehow
and then if this is the thing
the the amount
of time that you sit with that feeling
is how big of a [ __ ] bullshitter you
are you know what i'm talking about like
i meet rob dyrdick and that guy has it
all figured out and i sit there and i'm
like wow that's amazing and i i actually
think huh i you know i pride myself on
not being a big bullshitter i like to
shoot you straight right i like to shoot
people straight so sue me i like to
shoot people straight that's what i
that's what like my one of my things is
right if somebody says look at these
shoes and i don't like them i'm going to
say they're all right
unless i you know even if i don't you
know i tried to cultivate this whole
personality where it's like i'm there's
no bullshitter guy so if you meet me on
the street and the guy and you're a fan
of mine and you're like hey dude what's
up i'm gonna be like yo bro you're
making this mad awkward let's just chill
and you can just laugh at it cause you
know that's what you're gonna get right
i'm raw what you see is what you get
so i like to think i'm a straight
shooter but not everybody is a straight
shooter 100 of the time you're
bullshitting if that's what you think
so just try to shoot as straight as you
can
and you try to shoot a straight and
here's why you can't shoot as straight
as you possibly can 100 of the time
because you can't even shoot straight
with yourself
it's too hard to shoot straight with
yourself because not lying
is easy to do
on the whole but you lie to yourself
right
you do
you get oh this is not gonna be that bad
you know
right
you know you're stepping into an awful
party and you're just like oh this will
be all right i mean
you're tricking yourself
yeah you know what maybe it won't be
that oh you know dude right
so when rob dierdrick is like i do this
that this i write it all down and i
check my calories and i do this and i
got this many hours of sleep last night
and i'm going to get this much tonight
for a second i think wow i got to do
that kind of [ __ ]
and then
25 seconds later i think
i'll never do that actually
that's the amount of time i'm
bullshitting
25 seconds in that kind of a situation
but some people [ __ ] in that [ __ ]
oh rod deardrick said this i gotta go
get that app that he used to track his
[ __ ] i gotta make sure my sleep is this
bro if you meet somebody and they
convince you to download an app
you [ __ ]
use only the apps you need
minimalize that [ __ ]
now you're talking to a guy who has 150
pairs of shoes
you gotta treat yourself a little bit
but don't [ __ ] man
i'm not gonna [ __ ] and be like oh
yeah wear all these shoes all the time
now some of them [ __ ] suck [ __ ] you
know
but don't listen to me dude
don't freaking listen to me i say
franken because i'm trying to not say
[ __ ] around calvin
but rob deirdre man that guy
he was really an amazing guy to meet
it's so crazy man when i was a little
when i was a kid
i would watch like
um i read this book
uh
i said i'm saying like this like people
don't know one time one time somebody
said to me it was like i was in this
film called child's play and i was like
man i know
i'm like i know about chucky you don't
have to what what do you what kind of
person do you think i am
that i don't know what [ __ ] chuck he
is
i was in a little film called saving
private ryan i'm not sure if you've
heard it it was up for some academy
awards believe it or not but and i'm
like
tom hanks i know who you are
you know
oh mr spielberg thank you for
keeping me cool with the culture but
uh
what was i saying for [ __ ] sake about
the god damn it keva penton in effect
i was talking about uh rob dierdick and
then i was talking about
and he lost it
and he lost it oh when i was a kid
i read a book
we're back on track [ __ ] yeah dude
uh i read uh catcher in the rye
obviously it's one of the most famous
books of all time i shouldn't have to
say i read this book catch from the rye
but everybody's on tick tock now not
reading so maybe you don't know what
ketchup and rye is anymore but i read
ketones i had a profound effect on my
life i loved it i adopted my own
personality i tried to figure out who i
could be right that book was a coming of
age i was like who am i coming of age
and i adopted this personality of
you know who i thought was me but i was
probably just 16 and i was like um
i know
i i had this mentality like everybody's
the same
they're either gonna let you down
or like
[ __ ] with you and this is coming from a
guy who like had a great [ __ ]
upbringing i don't even know why i
adopted this [ __ ]
i'm a bit embarrassed by it but
my dad told me you know you say people
are all the same but you're you're gonna
be so shocked when you get older how
different people are
and i thought yeah you just don't get it
you just don't get it when i was 16 i
thought dad you just don't get it it's
so sad you lost your way
and uh
i'm 41 now
and i'm here to tell you i was right
no i was not right uh people are
different and it's [ __ ] crazy now
they all will do the same [ __ ] as people
i think what i was trying to say is like
people are the same when they're all
together they're pieces of [ __ ] but like
an individual a person is completely
different than another person
i'm so different from rob deirdre
and frankly he's better
he's better
oh dude one time i was [ __ ] when i
was i was i think i was 21 and i went to
a christmas concert hate concerts but i
went to a christmas concert you can go
to a christmas concert and that's okay
you know because you're like you're
doing something different because it's
christmas time and i was watching the
christmas concert and i was with my
girlfriend at the time and dude they
were going i will never forget this they
were going merry christmas to you what
this was the end of the concert and they
were going merry christmas to you all
merry christmas to you all merry
christmas to you all and they were
saying that way too [ __ ] much like so
much just merry christmas to you all and
this girl with really frizzy hair that
was in it and my eyes were just locked
on her for some reason she had the
frizziest hair merry christmas to you
all they started walking down the sides
of the auditorium on the on the [ __ ]
on the stairs merry christmas to you all
and they were just and this woman was
merry christmas to you all merry
christmas to you all going down the
stairs merry christmas to you everyone's
so jolly and not me dude i'm like what
the [ __ ] are they doing why is this
woman's hair so frizzy merry christmas
america down the stairs and she's going
down and says merry christmas to you all
dude she [ __ ]
stumbled dude she fell so [ __ ] hard
in her red sweater merry christmas to
you all and dude her frizzy hair just
went up in a puff and she goes merry
christmas to you oh
and she tried to grab someone else dude
they went down with her and boy for me
then did it become a merry [ __ ]
christmas dude
and that's my [ __ ] christmas
story to you and i tell that to calvin
every christmas eve when he goes to bed
and i scream it like i'm screaming now
he didn't really pay attention last year
because he was [ __ ] eight months old
but this year this motherfucker's gonna
understand me boy
merry christmas to you oh
dude i'll never forget that dude i will
never forget that it was so funny i
wonder who that woman is
she was probably 50 then
nah she was probably like late 40s
that's the greatest age to fall down the
stairs you know that's like the perfect
age of falling down the stairs is late
40s because any time before that you're
like ah they're all right and any time
after that like 55 you're like holy [ __ ]
this could be the le this could be the
end of that person
but [ __ ] that sweet spot of late 40s
falling down is perfect dude
you'll watch somebody fall down the
stairs all day when they're 48.
you'd be laughing the whole you won't
even help them you're just like holy
[ __ ] there goes frank just stumbling
stumbling stumbling like a goddamn
cartoon
just stumbling falling oh it's [ __ ]
hysterical
but when they're [ __ ] 19 or like 30
you're like ah they're gonna be okay
it's still funny but [ __ ] [ __ ] man 49
is when they do that oh
[ __ ] and you're just dying the right
amount of pain for that [ __ ] so
she went so when she merry christmas to
you all
she was at that sweet spot where i just
fell the [ __ ] off my chair dude forget
it everyone
i'm like you don't get it dude she's at
that sweet spot falling down the stairs
late 40s
right like if my dad fell down the
stairs right now i'd be like this is the
end that's it there you go he's 73. yeah
he's agile but dude he's 73. if he bonks
his head in the wrong way he's gone
um
yeah man
i was sitting on the couch with my dad
and calvin the other day
uh they were over for family dinner and
i was
i was talking to my dad and my dad was
like
um
had calvin in his arm
and i was next to calvin so it was like
the three of us
and uh my dad was like
hey calvin me and you
he goes like this hey calvin me and you
we're both in the same boat
and uh
i thought about what that might mean you
know at first i was like oh they're
delias we're all in the same boat but
then i was like [ __ ] man he's 73 and my
son
is a year and a half
you know it's that thing like my son is
becoming this [ __ ] person like every
day it's a new thing i think tamar is
going to wake up with stubble like it's
so new everything is new and he's
learning to do [ __ ] like i said the
other day he said sassa and now he says
santa he's learning [ __ ] he's got a t
and not only can he do it he can do it
in the middle of a [ __ ] word
that's something new
he didn't used to do that [ __ ]
he used to just say mama when mama was
downstairs and now he says mama dances
one day he's gonna wake up with some
goddamn stubble
right
he crawled out of bed the other day it
was hilarious we have friends staying
with us so we put [ __ ] calvin in in
his bed
in our room
bro it was [ __ ] hilarious i gotta get
back to my dad talk about my dad's story
about my dad but dude he he was in his
crib
chilling and um
kristen went in to go to bed
and uh
he woke up because she was tiptoeing in
and i was still [ __ ] busy you know
keeping it real italian watching gamora
till 3 a.m because that's how i [ __ ]
do it and i was i was just knee-deep in
[ __ ] mafia killings and drug drug
runnings and uh and then i came in and
when i came in he was still awake it was
[ __ ] four three o'clock in the
morning
and he stayed up till 4 30 dude and i
kept trying to bring him back and put
him in the cause now he doesn't have the
walls up because he's got the bed the
wall came out right we took the wall the
crib wall down
and now i'm like he can crawl out of the
bed so i'm like i'm in my bed in the
same room as him and i'm looking at the
[ __ ] nanite trying to fall asleep but
looking at the nanite because the room's
so dark and i see him with his [ __ ]
you know what i mean
like
with his [ __ ] night vision eyes just
staring sucking his thumb moving his
feet around i'm like this motherfucker's
not falling asleep but i'm watching the
nanite and
um
and i [ __ ] and i and i i decide okay
you know what i'm putting the nana away
i'm just gonna sleep
and so i put the phone down and because
that's keeping me up too so i'm going to
sleep and i'm like i don't even know if
calvin's sleeping or not and he is uh
not making a noise because he was going
like this for like an hour
like for an hour just whoa
whoa
and i'm just like jesus christ this
[ __ ] better be on a goddamn
seesaw when i turn the lights up
and uh and i look and and so i'm like oh
he's quite but now he's quiet so it's
like a little bit like
in the front part of my brain i'm like
oh he fell asleep but in the back part
of my brain i'm like but diddy
he could be [ __ ] quietly making an
omelette or some [ __ ] for all i know
right
you got to watch out for these babies
they just [ __ ] they'd be doing [ __ ]
right
they could be falling down hitting their
head and that's why they're quiet they
could be quietly [ __ ] the other day
he was eating a candle just straight up
eating a candle like it was the [ __ ]
snickers and i go kevin what are you
doing and he walks over me like this he
goes
and i just open your mouth and he opens
his mouth and i'm like trying to scrape
the [ __ ] wax off of his tongue and
he's like ah and i'm like what the [ __ ]
you did it bro
don't be eating candles so i left the
room took the candle
came back guess what he's eating another
[ __ ] candle so my point is these
babies be doing [ __ ]
with it without you so i'm like maybe i
gotta check on him i should check if
he's sleeping or not and i got the phone
down already i didn't want to wake up so
i skipped the nan apart and i just
sprung up
and i couldn't see it was really dark
and i crawl over to the foot of the bed
to try and go look at calvin in the bed
crib i said bed crib again because
there's not a wall on it it's just
[ __ ] three sides
and he is
not only
i'm focusing on where the crib is
and then my eyes focus
in i'm like at the foot of the bed my
eyes focus in
in front of me about
eight inches
and in focus
my son's face all of a sudden
and he quietly says
ha data
if you think it didn't scare the [ __ ]
out of me
yeah out of your mind
he goes ha tata
don't be so creepy calvin
not at [ __ ] 3 a.m when i'm i mean
dude it scared the sh
i'm like oh my i got so scared i didn't
you know what i mean when you get those
there's a levels of scare to scare you
like oh that's kind of scary yeah wow
and then there's oh [ __ ] you're like oh
you jumped that's the scared dude
there's a level past that where you
don't even move and you just are like
okay okay cool i got to go check if i if
i [ __ ] myself
um
anyway
babies be doing [ __ ] is what i'm saying
so so uh
so now i gotta go back to the story
where my dad was
he said we're in the same boat
and i'm like
i let my mind kind of wander what that
means the
you know babies grow up and they become
people and
moms and dads and grand grandmas and
grandpas i should say
it's like that benjamin button thing you
know it's like
grandmas and grandpas get to that age
where they're like [ __ ]
the
they look like they're a third of the
way into the movie benjamin buttons into
the movie you know what i mean
it's like a third of the way where
you're like the old guy but you're
becoming young and you're like oh it
still looks kind of weird because you're
short and old and [ __ ]
you know it's like a third of the way
into the benjamin buttons movie that's
what [ __ ] grandmas and grandpas start
to look like when they're on their way
out
and so i'm like [ __ ] dude
that's a boat too
you know
at some point you just pass each other
the grandmas and the grandsons the
grandpas and the granddaughters you just
pass each other on that way on the way
out and on the way up
and you're just like we're basically the
same at this point right
i mean i saw when my
when my grandma died it was like she
didn't know who anybody was
my grandma died and she uh
was so messed up in the head she had
cancer and
she didn't recognize anybody
she was in the hospital and uh
and she was uh
she didn't know who like her grandson
was
and
that was uh
that was a tough thing to [ __ ] see
but also like
i mean my
aunt
brought a card
from
jordan
uh and jordan was how old must have
jordan been when he was
when my grandma died
must have been
the age to where it was hard for him to
write his name but he could do it you
know
he did it with a crayon he wrote a note
for her and my aunt his mom put it in an
envelope
and uh
gave it to her
gave it to his mom to give it to grandma
because he wasn't going to go to the
hospital because also it was very weird
like she couldn't really recognize
people and she was
you know on her way out and um
and he uh
and it said and he wrote his name on the
thing and
my
uncle his dad gave
the um
the note
to my grandma carmella satalian but
that's her name and we called her karmzy
it's italian and um
when she gave it to him
he said she opened it up and she read it
and she said
oh
that's uh
so sweet it's fr she looked at the name
and she said it's from
it's from sherrod
and my uncle mike said
what
no
it's from your grandson
and she said
and he said no your grandson jordan it
says jordan
and then
my grandma said
well then who's sharad
and that's hysterical
but it's also sad
um
because [ __ ] charade is goddamn no
one
you made it up
now we gotta act like sharad's a person
now every now we always [ __ ] stand
our family who's charade if we have a
laugh man
[Laughter]
um
so yeah man my dad's doing well i'm not
trying to say he's on his way out he's
not but like uh it just got me thinking
you know there is that moment where the
[ __ ] grandson
and the grandfather
have to look at each other
and they're like there's that's there's
that moment where you're where they look
at each other and you're like oh [ __ ]
we're the same at this point
but i gotta leave and you gotta [ __ ]
become
wow that's pretty crazy
um i would still honestly trust my dad
driving more than calvin driving though
so we're good we got some years left we
got maybe we got at least a decade left
maybe um
i just wonder if secretly that was the
boat he was talking about
let's do some misconnections and then
let's wrap this up huh
i should say go to crystallia.com finish
your christmas shopping go to uh cameo
get your christmas uh [ __ ]
things last
you know what if i'm trying to say i
don't didn't do the sentence right but
um
here we go let's do some of these here
uh you were in your 40s
why is there a dash there makes no sense
it says back then you were in you were
in the sfv san francisco valley i assume
you had longish hair and liked that i
could relate to much of what you were
about and dealing with
wow
sad um here's another one looking for my
good amigo like how we switched it to uh
spanish right there
uh looking from a good friend to play
with kama kama kama kama kama dude it's
dot like these guys who like do you not
seriously know it's dot i thought and
then married guy here
sneaky do not contact him with solicited
services
unsolicited services or offers
here we go
guy i used to know
that's the gay usher writing this one
looking for a guy wasn't wasn't that him
you used to know okay or oh no who's
that somebody that i used to know was
that [ __ ] guy
go ta change it um
goat change it guy i used to know
uh but also usher did have a song like
that uh looking for a guy who would like
to have his feet worshipped
cut to the chase dude what's with the
guy he used to know
looking for a guy hey guy i used to know
anyway looking for a guy who would like
to have his feet worshipped
two [ __ ] different things
that would be like if you [ __ ] had a
book and it said the client on it and
you opened it up and it was andromeda
strain different
well those are deep pulls um do oh here
we go dude for dude
oh the body of this one
unreal
chill sit back in hollywood now
hey guy
if you've got enough time to write a
post add more words than that
chill chill
sit back in hollywood now
is this sit back a gay term i don't know
about
um here's another one handyman for
service granada hills dude some crazy
[ __ ] goes down into granada hills uh hi
there oh this is a haiku practically we
just met at home depot you need a
handyman service wow so [ __ ] giving
him the telling him business right now
you
oh oh this actually happened never mind
hi there we just met at home depot you
needed a handyman service invited me
over i cleaned your pipe and took care
of the nuts and bolts you had laying
around
let me know if you need more service
just say it
don't add end bolts you know we get it
just say
i serviced your [ __ ] and nuts
i cleaned your pipe and took care of the
nuts i like how he adds and bolts in
case in case in case the feds is
watching
here's another one
wow the title on this one
what about my umbrella
with a question mark say fernando valley
did this one start in the middle of a
conversation
here's the body you have my umbrella
from last year and i need it i mean dude
if you needed it that bad a year ago
if you didn't that bad should have had
it already um you have my umbrella for a
from last year and now i need it i lost
your number you send me a picture of it
and i'll come over and get it asap means
[ __ ] i honestly at this one hope it
means [ __ ] because he if he just means
umbrella
hey guy go out and get a new nine cent
umbrellas you can get an umbrella in one
of those [ __ ] things you put a coin
in and twist the turnstile thing
umbrellas are cheap dude hey guy hold up
a magazine above your head
hey man really need that umbrella i or i
gave you a year ago
not [ __ ] around it is gonna be wet
outside
here's an issue of shape magazine hold
it above your head
um
the older here's another one the older
we get the colder it feels
ah [ __ ]
robert frost here huh
robert frost here the older we get the
colder it feels
the older we get the colder it feels by
rabbit frost
here's the body how to stay warm any
thoughts i'm from 50 light years away
oh
the next word
stopped too soon
how to stay warm any thoughts i'm from
50 light years away
mars
is venus close to the same distance
hey guy
go to the doctor
right this guy should write the guy with
the umbrella post got your umbrella
it's on mars
hey guys that's the episode for today on
youtube if you want to catch the
extended uncut version uh go over on
over to our patreon patreon.com
crystalia and you get all of the patreon
only episodes i think there's about 10
or 11 now uh backlogged you get access
to those immediately now for six bucks
and there's also different segments that
we do like review mode we've got extra
patreon footage like the stuff that i
did with brian callan at the gun range
just [ __ ] like that so go on over to
patreon.comcrystalia
and check it out thanks
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
my son would say
oh it's very cute